le département de la réunion aux côtés
des réunions la prestation de
compensation du handicap est une aide
personnalisée destinée à financer les
besoins liés à la perte d'autonomie des
personnes porteuses d'un handicap
elle prend en compte les besoins de la
personne afin de lui permettre de se
maintenir à domicile
ce dispositif est une compétence
obligatoire du département
à qui s'adresse-t-il la pch s'adresse
aussi bien aux adultes qu'aux enfants
elle peut prendre en charge des aides
humaines des aides techniques d
aménagement du domicile du véhicule et
des surcoûts résultants du transport des
charges spécifique ou exceptionnelles et
des aides animalière son attribution et
personnalisés vous pouvez retirer un
dossier auprès de la mdph la maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
tous renseignements vous pouvez
contacter en priorité la mdph au 0 800
000 262 vos www.mts.ca heureux également
la dpa ph
la direction des personnes âgées et des
personnes handicapées aux services
coordination des dispositifs d aide
sociale personnes âgées personnes
handicapées au 02 62 90 35 51
et